yeah welcome a five-minute game against
international master do trio from
Belgium playdom quite often here
recently um mostly we played those kind
of opening see seems to play that often
yeah this exchange is very odd not too
promising for white but in this some
particular case I get a quick long
castles another kind of course white
never place efore because it would
weaken the d4 square this wins another
temple o king aid this is a bit a bit
odd black tries to play c6 King c7 can I
reviewed it in some way it looks it is
very uncommon to do that now be high on
ID five he's got night a eight and I
don't see a great follow-up to that
hmm
yeah let's stick to the normal plan the
normal plane he is g4g form and he
prevents it with h5 trusting so h3c
going to play h4 maybe okay i need to do
that anyway at some point covering see
find and try to develop the bishop yeah
should I should I play g3 even g3 h3g
form to make sure he doesn't play age
for himself I think I don't want h3 and
h4 by black it bit of a pest okay this
way it takes a while but i but i managed
to play G form the idea of the
smoothness to make it difficult wow wow
what an ugly moves the idea is to fight
for the e4 square which she just handed
to me right on a plate okay Bishop d3 to
a five-year and then nitey format it's
not it's not one hundred percent clear
cut but it looks well I don't like it so
how to how to continue of course i'd
like to exchange on f5 and not recapture
with the porn this is simply only the
second best way to do it let me first
cover this this despondence on
once you form a night to g3 would be
nice okay let's secure this I don't want
to be hit with 95 with the temple then
try to regroup in a way that I get the
next change of the bishop on f5 without
needing to recapture that the porn goes
to have five as usual the only problem
was the time spent this intense night h
292 g3 this kind of maneuver it's a bit
slow yeah he wants to play a four bit
it's not much that I can do about that
I know this looks som this is in ninety
percent of the cases a bed response to a
four but I hope that the light squared
bishopsgate exchanged so it's not maybe
it is bad after all if maybe it is bad
after all okay I Scott beehive my king
that's not good i'm glad that he didn't
play b5 the sort of pin would have been
dangerous I think I place it in a very
in a very strategical long-term fashion
improving the night and so on this is a
fine I mean it's playing it all right
just the the more aggressive way seemed
seem to be a seem to be much more
dangerous to me okay so let's um let's
see I want to play c4 c5 but i'm okay i
needed to cover the porn first this is
necessary here to have added something
he could have considered to play c5
himself
yeah I think it just needs to take it
what else
yeah very double-edged position now
Double H means I don't know what is
going on
he must um yeah this should be 6m it
should be six as a big threat should be
six king c 3 a 5 on solid dating all
this
surprising it doesn't prevent it could
have plates maybe c5 himself on b5 route
8 unaware I control eight-hour okay yeah
well then then this position is good for
me I think unless there's some syntactic
the time of course i'm down to 50
seconds this is it this is ugly the
position is excellent I think
wise it's got his burning time as well
all kinds of end games are winning for
me you can change all the rooks and he
resigns the apron went slack resign oh
this this is early that surprised me I
mean the time is an issue the position
is terrible for black hair pretty sure
my computers or plus two already yeah
I'm now I have everything controlled now
and he needed to do something beforehand
I'm now just just pushing the a porn I
cannot somehow I'm not an examination
mode don't know and now I am pushing the
a porn and this is weak he doesn't have
a good move really that's um it's very
annoying computer wants to play this but
what is this film no I can even play
here okay and then then push the a porn
but now then it's going to look h1 ok
and this ok gathers I probably wouldn't
have flipped if done AI just take here
take t5 is this is always got this look
edge one count of play yeah this isn't
so clear I mean why did you resign I
don't I don't know it looks it looks
very ugly maybe he didn't didn't really
think about Bishop d5 if you don't play
Bishop b5 you're you're out of moves
basically what are you playing you have
only have like zero moves like this
which yeah which doesn't improve yeah
very early resignation I think one in
one point was that here he needed to do
something about the c4c fire threat and
of course there was this b5 moment
that would have been very ugly if he
goes b5 now I think I'm just exploding
yeah minus 1 something by the comp I'm
just I'm just exploding so a 4 was
really a crap move here I shouldn't play
a form normal Rufus 94 or something
trying to exploit the squares that if I
and i would like to this is wrong what I
would love to do is get get the night to
g3 I'm making all this more arrows here
efore g3 but without of course losing
the g4 pot so that at one point I can
play Bishop f5 and exchange those two
and this would be very nice because at
the end he's with this very bad bishop
on g7 it's not so easy to accomplish
well a 4 was bad in account of the the
upcoming b5 by black and my king is
really a problem so very unclear game
yeah thanks for watching